hello and welcome to a brief clip from
gamespot of Thrones if you'd like to
watch the full episode head over to
youtube.com slash gamespot but if you
continue to watch here be aware of
spoilers okay do you want to kick things
off with Sansa and little finger yes so
we saw that little thing is going to be
in the next episode again and through
the magic of really fast Westeros
transport he notices to meet up with
Sansa which I was quick especially cuz
it took us so long to get anywhere so we
know that there's going to be five
thousand men versus two thousand men in
bastard ball but maybe it won't be that
unfair a fight if the veil and they're
well-trained if slightly boring men join
in so Santa who's leading the fight to
most people surprise because John has no
backbone and also died she meets
Littlefinger the dude who sort of
accidentally married her off to Ramsay
Bolton and that didn't go very well for
her but it's likely they're going to
make up because first of all little
finger has the men santa needs and
second of all Littlefinger always gets
his way especially if it happens to be
the daughter of his creepy dead crush
and dave well it looks like area the
assassin is going to get her first him
and contract we see her given what
appears to be a bottle of poison hmm but
then ish but then she is told does death
only come for the wicked and leave the
decent behind that's interesting who
could it be there's gotta be someone in
old town right well that's the thing
like this could be the start of her
crisis of conscience like maybe
shouldn't expect that she would have to
kill the innocent yeah but what appears
to be good people in the last person she
killed was so Meryn Trant who definitely
deserved it so this might kind of clash
with her moral compass of who she
believes deserves death mmm if they're
not on her list she doesn't really want
to kill them right yeah but they're just
bad people yeah and finally we get to
see more bran bran to be honest I've
been enjoying the Brian segments just
because you know one step closer you
enjoy power of choice oh yeah alright
you would've enjoyed it regardless
and so in this we can see the bronze
walking so that obviously suggests that
it's a green dream because obviously
they can't walk in real life also you
can see mirror trying to wake him up so
that's kind of interesting because is he
has he gone dreaming by himself without
the three-eyed Raven and that's why he
can't wake up because if we see like
he's with the night's king maybe the
night's king is like instead him into a
dream and he can't leave that's creepy
well what's interesting is what dream
like what is he looking at so we could
see like the big army of the others
mm-hmm they seem to be like at the
three-eyed Ravens kind of place because
they can't seem to go past one line
because the magic there was a powerful
or whatever so I think maybe he's gone
back to the original like the original
long the long night which is where the
others came down and it was like a time
of darkness and the long winter and
famine and people like the first met
almost died but then they rally together
in the battle for the dawn with the
first people so there's like the green
people as well and that's when azure a
high as well wielding light bringer came
to kind of put an end to the long night
so it'd be interesting to see if Brian's
gone back to look at that especially
with the the revelation when this week
that Melisandre is like yeah John's
definitely the prince that was promised
why I want to know is why is he looking
at that and not looking at what's inside
the tower y reckon it might be that bran
goes I want to look at more terror of
joy stuff because I want to confirm our
+ l equals Jake's bran is all of us come
on now Brian but in unguided meditation
he just randomly picks at a memory and
then has to watch it yeah he doesn't
know how to use the remote Simon an
Nana's brand Oh confirmed
you